شكرا لك ايمان ومرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه
النافذه للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب
اسرائيل على قطاع غزه فيها طبعا نستضيف
المحلل العسكري اللواء فايز الدويري
ونتابع بدايه اخر تطورات المشهد ميدانيا
على الخريطه التفاعليه مع عبد القادر
عراضه اليك عبد القا نعم السي وعلي سانطرح
من اخر الاخبار المتعلقه باطلاق صواريخ من
المقاومه حيث وقبل قليل تابعنا اعلان
سرايا القدس عن اطلاق صواريخ باتجاه اسدود
السلطات الاسرائيليه تتحدث عن اسقاط خمسه
صواريخ من اصل تسعه اذا هذا احدث تطور في
الحرب على غزه وشاهدناه قبل قليل بالعوده
الى التطورات الاخرى وتحديدا حينما ننتقل
الى منطقه الشمال كان هناك حديث اسرائيلي
عن سحب القوه او الفرقه رقم 36 وذلك هذه
الفرقه التي تتشكل من مجموعه من الالويه
بما فيها سلاح الهندسه والفرقه السادسه
والسابعه ورقم 188 هذه الفرقه التي كانت
قد تحركت وكانت انطلقت منذ بدايه بدايات
الحرب والتوغل الاسرائيلي خصوصا في مناطق
بيت حانون وايضا في منطقه بيت لاهيه وكانت
ايضا تحركت ايضا في المناطق الغربيه لكن
اللافت هو ما اعلنه الجيش الاسرائيلي عن
عمليه انسحاب لهذه القوات او لهذه الاليات
التي كانت متمركزه بالاساس في المنطقه
الشماليه وحينما نشير الى هذه التطورات
المتعلقه بالانسحاب او اعاده التموضع او
اعاده الانتشار ونترك ذلك للتحليل العسكري
في توصيف هذا الخبر ياتي ذلك بينما تعرضت
مناطق عديده من شمال قطاع غزه الى عمليه
قصف اسرائيلي كان مراسلنا تحدث عن عمليه
استهداف في وسط غزه وادى الى استشهاد نحو
33 فلسطينيا كان هناك ايضا استهداف من
ايضا من البحر لمنطقه تل الهواى وايضا
الشيخ عجلين وذلك قبل بضعه بضع ساعات اذا
مع هذا الانسحاب المعلن تاتي عمليه القصف
لاكثر من منطقه في في الشمال بذهاب الى
المنطقه الوسطى حينما نتحدث عن المنطقه
الوسطى وهي المنطقه التي كانت الفرقه 36
في الحد
من ديسمبر بعد ما ان اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي بانها تمكنت من تفكيك مقال
القدرات القتاليه لحماس في الشجاعيه كانت
قد انتقلت نحو جحر الديك وحينما نتحدث عن
جحر الديك نتحدث ايضا عن انتقالها الى
المناطق الوسطى وهي بالتحديد في منطقه
البريج في هذه المنطقه تحديدا تناولنا
ايضا الاخبار العاجله المتعلقه بعملي قصف
لمنطقه مناطق في البريج ولكن كان ايضا
حديث لكتائب القسام عن عن استهدافها ايضا
لقوه راجله لقوه راجله هنا في منطقه
البريج وايضا استهداف مجموعه من الاليات
في المنطقه الوسطى في المنطقه الوسطى
القصف ايضا طال مناطق النصيرات والزوايده
ولكن المغازي كان اللافت هو استهداف
المغازي في المنطقه الوسطى بالقنابل
الفسفوريه اذا المنطقه الوسطى لازالت
بالنسبه ل الجيش الاسرائيلي مساحه اشتباك
ومواجهه ولعل الفرق الفرق الثلاث الي التي
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي عن بقائها في قطاع
غزه من بينها احدى الفرق التي تتولى
العمليات في المنطقه الوسطى وتحديدا في
منطقه وادي غزه ننتقل الى المنطقه الاخيره
وهي المنطقه الجنوبيه احدث خبر كنا
تناولناه هو اعلان كتائب القسام عن اجها
زها على قوه عسكريه اسرائيليه في المنطقه
في شرق خان يونس ومنطقه شرق خان يونس
والجنوب الشرقي كان دوما مسرحا لاشتباكات
عنيفه كان هناك استهداف لاليات عسكريه
ايضا في اكثر من موقع كما اعلنت القسام
وايضا سرايا القدس على جبهات متعدده في
المنطقه الجنوبيه اذا تطورات في الجنوب في
الوسط وفي الشمال ولكن السي لعل الابرز
وهذه الانسحابات او اعاده الانتشار
المعلنه من قبل الجيش الا بالفعل وكل ذلك
عبد القادر سنتناوله مع اللواء فايز لواء
فايز لو بدانا بالقصف اليوم ما الذي يلفت
في العمليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه يعني
الان يجب ان نفرق بين المناطق الثلاث في
المنطقه الشماليه هذا القصف ياخذ اشكال
متعدده اولا قصف مدفعي وقصف من الطائرات
وقصف من البحر هذا تعامل مع اهداف محدده
في في القاطع الشمالي بناء على معطيات
ميدانيه واهم هذه المعطيات المدنيه ظهور
ظهور
مقاتلين الحديث
عن
انفاق الحديث عن احتماليه وجود رهائن لانه
في بعض الحالات هذا القصف يكون متبوعا
بحركه ارضيه القوات الان هي
خارج القاطع الشمالي على ح دود في بعض
الحالات بعمق مئات الامتار وفي معظم
الحالات هي خلف
السياج لكن في وادي غزه طريق رقم 10 لا
لانه الطريق رقم 10 هي تعتبر الحد الفاصل
من وجهه نظر عسكريه اسرائيليه ما بين
القاطع الشمالي والقاطع الاوسط هذه تاتي
فيها اطراف الزيتون والاطراف الجنوبيه
للرمال وتل الهواء وفوق ذلك جحر الديك هذه
المنطقه تتعرض الى قصف شديد على شكل احزمه
ناريه لماذا لانها لا ترغب بالزج بالقوات
الى هذه المناطق لانه هذه المناطق كانت
مزعجه جدا وهي المناطق التي نجحت في تنفيذ
العديد من العمليات النوعيه في منطقه
الوسط الوضع مختلف هناك الفرقه 99 تتشكل
من اربعه الويه فيها لواء مدرع واحد فيها
لواء مظليين فيها لوائين مشاه الان هذه
الالويه هذه الالويه لا تعمل بالصيغه
التنظيميه الحقيقيه نجد يتم المزج ما بين
قوات المشا والمظليين والدروع في تنظيم
قتالي جديد من اجل تحقيق المهمه وتم تخصيص
ما ما يعرف بلواء لكل نقطه من هذه النقاط
الاربعه الريجن سيارات الزوايده المغازي
لا يزال القتال من حيث انجازاته منذ 48
ساعه ثابت الانجاز الوحيد تمثل في عمليه
اندفاع سريع من اللواء المدرع وتجاوزت
حدود منطقه المغازي الزوايده ووصلت الى
اطراف دير البلح الى
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى هذا هو الانجاز
الوحيد في هذه
المنطقه في نفس الاطار لواء فايز ما اهميه
الاعلان اليوم عن سحب هذه
الفرقه من قطاع غزه هو يعني الان هو ليس
سحب هو تبديل قوات ام الفرقه 36 كما اشار
كانت في المنطقه الشماليه
وتعرضت لخسائر كبيره خاصه لوا جولاني الذي
سحبت احد كتائبه من منطقه الشجاعيه من اجل
اعاده التاهيل فهذه الفرقه خاضت معارك في
غرب مدينه غزه وفي القاطع الشمالي تحديدا
في في منطقه الشجاعيه والخط المستمر من
الشجاعيه تعرضت الى خسائر كبيره مع التوجه
للمرحله الثالثه ماذا جرى تم سحب الثلاثه
فرق وهي الفرقه 36 والفرقه 162 والفرقه
256 الفرقه 36 سحبت قبل الفرق الاخرى
لماذا لانها كلفت بواجب جديد هذا الواجب
تمثل في التعامل مع منطقه الوسط منطقه
المخيمات هذه ال هذه رقه تركيب التاء
معظمها الويه مدرعه باستثناء لواء جولاني
لا تتناسب طبيعه المهمه ولا تتناسب طبيعه
الجغرافيا لهذا السبب اخفقت في تحقيق ايه
انجازات يعتد بها على مدار اكثر من اسبوع
عشره ايام لذلك صحبت و لهذا السبب تم
تبديلها ا الان الانسحاب جاء م
مرحلا بناء على توازن القوى في منطقه
المعركه كانت سلمت قياده منطقه العمليات
للفرقه 99 وهي في معظمها ثلاثه لواء
مظليين لواء كوماندوس لواء مشا ولواء مدرع
تم اعاده خلق هذه القوات في في توليفه
جديده بدا بدفع هذه القوات وكان يتم
استغلال اللحظات التي تجبر فيها القوات
على الانسحاب تكون القوات التي القادمه
للفرقه 99 في حاله تاخ
عندما ينسحب لواء من محيط البريج وانسحب
اكثر من مره ويعود الى منطقه السياج الذي
كان يعود بعد 24 ساعه ليس اللواء اللواء
القادم من الفرقه 99 لكن ما جرى في هذا
اليوم هو اكمال انسحاب هذه الفرقه وانسحبت
تحت القتال وكان هناك اسناد ناري واستخدام
السواتر الترابيه السواتر الدخانيه من اجل
فك الاشتباك عندما يتم الحديث الان عن
اعاده تاهيل هذه الفرقه التي انسحبت وربما
نشرها في مكان اخر ماذا نتوقع الان هناك
عده
احتمالات ابدا بالاحتمال الاعلى انا اتصور
هذه الفرقه لم يعد هناك حاجه لها للقتال
في غزه لماذا لانه المنطقه الشماليه سحبت
القوات منها المنطقه الوسطى تم احلال فرقه
مكان فرقه المنطقه الجنوبيه يوجد فيها
فرقتين يوجد فيها الفرقه 98 ويوجد به
الفرقه
100 و43 او ما يطلق عليها فرقه غزه معززه
بالويه نخبه وكتائب نخفه فهناك فائض قوه
في المنطقه الجنوبيه اذا لا يوجد حاجه
ميدانيه لها اما قد ان تعود لاعاده
التاهيل والاستراحه او قد ترسل الى مناطق
اخرى على سبيل المثال شمال فلسطين المحتله
على حدود لبنان ضمن اطار عمل المنطقه
العسكريه الشماليه اريد ان اتوق وقف معك
لواء فايز عند تصريحات اليوم لمسؤولين
اسرائيليين لا سما وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
الذي قال
ان العمليات العسكريه تقريبا انجزت كل
اهدافها في شمال قطاع غزه مازال القتال
مستمرا في الوسط والجنوب ولكن عام
2024 سيكون عام حرب هذا هو ما يقوله هذا
هو ما يقوله هذا خطاب شعبوي ورئيس الوزراء
يعلم ان ايقاف الحرب هي نهايتهم السياسيه
ويذهب سيذهب احدهم الى مزبله التاريخ
والاخر الى السجن بسبب قضايا الفساد اذا
بقاؤه خارج هذا الاطار هو من خلال
الاستمرار القتالي هو تحدث وقال انه تم من
خلال الضغط الع العسكري انقاذ 110 رهائن
ام وهو كاذب واعتذر عن استخدام مفردات من
خلال الجزيره هو يكذب على شعبه ال 110 تم
تم اخلاء سبيلهم بعمليه من خلال مفاوضات
ووسطاء ومن خلال هدنه سبعه ايام هو لم
يستطع ان ينقذ جندي واحد هو يحاول انقاذ
رقبته بحجه العشره لكن لواء فايز عندما
يقول وزير الدفاع ان عام 2024 سيكون عام
حرب ماذا نتوقع هذا ما يقوله الان تفسير
كلمه الحرب يعني ماذا عفوا ولكن بالمعنى
ماذا بقي من اهداف
ليم هو الان بقيت المنطقه الوسطى ويقاتل
بها ولا يوجد انجاز عسكري نعم هو فصل
المخيمات عن بعضها البعض لم يحقق ايه
اختراقات دخل في
منطقه لو اعطيتنا لو سمحت المنطقه الوسطى
الان في منطقه
البريج نعم البريج محاصر ولكنه دخل في
بحدود 500 متر في المنطقه الجنوبيه لمنطقه
المقبره ام في منطقه صيرات توقف العمليات
الهجوميه وتوقفت على الواجهه الشماليه في
الزوايده اللواء الذي اندفع من غرب
الصيرات ووصل الزوايده ويدعم بالنيران
والنيران من البحر استطاع ان ان يدخل الى
منطقه المنتزه في اقصى الشمال الغربي من
الزوايده المغازي تم كذلك كما قلت محاصرته
ودخل الى بعض الاجزاء وتوقف القتال بهذا
الوضع الان اذا ذهبنا الى الجنوب لا تزال
الوض القتاليه كما هي منذ اكثر من ع ايام
لا يوجد فيها انجاز الانجاز الوحيد كان
الحركه من منطقه الفخاري الى منطقه قازان
النجار وسيطر على دخل قاز لم يسيطر دخل
قازان النجار في اليوم الثاني اجبر على
التخلي بقي القتال في ثلاثه نقاط داخل
مدينه خان يونس الكتيبه والمحطه والسجن
اخلى منطقه القراره وزنيه يحاول ان يضغط
من عبسان ال الجديده من الجناح الشمالي
ومن عبسان الكبيره من ال الناحيه الجنوبيه
ودفع بلواء الى منطقه خزاعه ولم يستطع ان
يدخلها اذا المعركه في حاله سكون ولا يوجد
انجازات وبالتالي لم يعد هناك ما ما يتحدث
عنه اذا الحديث عن حاله الاستمرار حاله
الحرب معنى مجازي من خلال الع العمليات
الجراحيه النوعيه على كل اريد ان نعيد
ونذكر بالخبر الذي تناولناه قبل قليل
بلديه سديروت اعلنت انها اعترضت خمسه من
اصل تسع صواريخ جرى اطلاقها من داخل قطاع
غزه طبعا نشاهد هذه الصور قبل قليل لهذه
الصواريخ التي اطلقت من داخل القطاع وهذا
اهميه هذا التطور ياتي ايضا بعد ان كان
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي قال ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يجهز على مصانع الصواريخ في
الداخل هو هو هو هذا ما قاله وانا اجبت
على هذه النقطه بالامس كان هناك كمان رشقه
صاروخ على سديروت واليوم في هذا رشقه
صاروخ بالامس كانت تحديدا من المنطقه
الشماليه في هذا اليوم لم تحدد المنطقه
وبالتالي هذه كانت رد واضح رد في البعد
السياسي وفي البعد العسكري ان ما تقولوا
لشعبك غير دقيق انت مخادع لنفسك مخادع
لشعبك ها نحن نطلق الصواريخ في الوقت الذي
نشاء من المكان الذي نشاء الى الاتجاه
الذي نشاء اشكرك اللواء فايز دويري الخبير
العسكري الاستراتيجي وبهذا مشاهدينا نصل
الى نهايه هذه النافذه عوده الان الى
ايمان في غرفه الاخبار شكرا لك